okay so long time Trump friend confidant
advisor Roger stone who of course had a
huge huge role with Richard Nixon in the
1970s has been arrested in a very early
morning raid by the FBI this morning we
are still learning about the charges
against him the counts and what we're
going to play for you today was my
interview with him not that long ago
during which he of course denied all
wrongdoing by everybody there's just
nothing happened nothing to see here and
what's very interesting about this
interview is that I'm still not exactly
sure how it happened because at the time
that the center of you took place Roger
stone started to sort of reduce his
media presence as it started to become
it was still very early in the suspicion
that he may be wrapped up in the Moller
probe and maybe someday would be
indicted
but he didn't cancel our interview which
we fully expected him to do and a funny
anecdote about it before we get to the
interview is that when we connected with
Roger stone for the interview it was his
assistant who made the connection and
because that happened the connection was
made via Skype before the interview
actually started so we were able to hear
a conversation that was taking place in
the background and the conversation
between Roger stone and his staff was
that he didn't want to do the interview
he wanted to cancel it he was sort of
like do we absolutely have to do this
his staff said well we're connected I
mean it's happening it's happening now
and indeed the interview ended up taking
place here's what was in that interview
of course now with the arrest and
indictment we have a lot more context
and information surrounding what was
discussed I'm joined today by Roger
stone who is a political consultant New
York Times bestselling author and author
of the new book the making of the
President 2016 how Donald Trump
orchestrated a revolution Roger you're
an in-demand guy these days it seems
everybody including people in government
want to talk to you did you predict that
everything surrounding what is
now going on with this presidency would
would blow up in the way that it has and
that you'd be such a part of it well in
my book making you the president 2016 I
really went out of my way to lay the
groundwork to expose this myth that
Donald Trump's campaign somehow colluded
with or was assisted by the Russians hmm
it's all there in chapter and verse and
of course it requires some update with
the new inferences by members of
Congress who have inaccurately and
falsely accused me of such collusion for
which there is no evidence whatsoever
certainly no evidence that would ever
stand up in a u.s. court of law so I
think it's becoming clearer and clearer
that the whole idea of Russian collusion
with Trump or the Trump campaign was the
excuse the justification the rationale
if you will for surveillance of Trump
Tower and the president and some of his
associates it's certainly according to
the New York Times of January 20th page
one wiretapped data utilized in probe of
Trump associates is the headline that
would be made that my conversations with
Donald Trump were most certainly
monitored during the fall of last year
well now let's dig into that a little
bit right because at the center of a lot
of this is the allegation made by Devin
Nunez who of course is in charge of the
house investigation into potential
collusion between Trump and Russia what
he alleged and whether it's true remains
to be seen is that in surveillance by
American intelligence agencies of
foreign entities that there were Trump
associates picked up because they were
in communication with those foreign
entities that's very different than
surveillance of conversations between
you and and the president which I've not
seen any evidence for well the evidence
of course would be that all my
communications were monitored
female according to the January 30th New
York Times cell phone conversations so
they're by definition my conversations
whether it is with reporters or my wife
or Donald Trump candidate for president
were in fact monitor I also don't think
we're at the end of this scandal as I
have written the path pardon me the
operation dragnet that was put in place
by the NSA right after 9/11 has
monitored a substantial number of
Americans phone calls and the records
indicate coming from a federal lawsuit
in Arizona the Donald Trump was among
those being surveilled so I think this
is a developing story what chairman
Nunez showed us was disturbing because
to be very clear the FBI director mr.
Comey and at Mirage errs the NSA
director both said under oath there was
no no surveillance going on at Donald
Trump at Trump Tower and of course that
now proves to be false but it doesn't
really because if someone at Trump Tower
was being surveilled because they were
in contact with a foreign entity that
was being surveilled that's very
different then then surveillance of
Trump Tower itself and I'm wondering if
there's a sort of song I don't agree
employed here to muddy the waters I
don't agree surveillance is surveillance
I think we're going to learn that there
was more surveillance than we've been
told like you I also have sources and
I'm working this story very hard so
let's let that play out okay I go back I
go back to this simple question which is
if you look at the times of the 20th and
you and again on the 30th the
intelligence sources tell the times that
they have email transmissions they have
copies of financial documents and then
on the 30th they add transcripts of
telephone intercepts between Trump
associates and some
Russian contact as far as I am concerned
I'd like to see them because in my case
they do not exist okay that's fair and
let's let's focus then let's wait for
that to play out and focus on what's
happened so far I'm genuinely curious as
one of Donald Trump's closest confidants
I don't know how often you speak to him
now but at least at one point why do you
believe that if there is nothing to hide
with regard to the Russia connections
and alleged collusion why do you believe
that so many people have been caught
lying about meetings with Russian
associates and I know not I'm not making
this list for you I know you know it but
for our audience this involves disgraced
National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn's lies about the content of
communications with Russian ambassador
Sergey kis lyac this includes Jeff
sessions and what we now know to have
been two or three meetings with that
same ambassador you could include Carter
Paige Jared Kushner etc aside from
whether or not you believe there was
collusion how do you explain the lies
well I don't have to explain them
because I am none of those people I I
can't tell you what general Flynn may or
may not have done I tend to believe Paul
Manafort who have known for over 40
years was a UH sure in my wedding mm-hmm
we were we both come from Connecticut we
were active in college and then later
Young Republicans I choose to believe
that he also had no collusion or
contacts with the Russians the fact that
he had a contract with a Russian
oligarch that ended in 2009 an oleg arc
by the way who met privately with John
McCain while he was running for
president does not prove collusion in
this campaign okay but we have to any
more detail Roger we've got to dig into
that in detail because you're on record
I mean on August 15 on the Alex Jones
Show which is a whole other set of
conversations and questions we could
have you said that Paul Manafort has
never worked for the Ukrainian
government or for the Russian government
you said on August 18th on Breitbart
that is still accurate and that is still
accurate well only if you want to play a
very muddy semantic game because it's
widely known now that he has
multiple contracts furthering Russian
interests and today I believe that only
if you are going in a semantic direction
is that true you've been proven to have
either you didn't know or you lied about
that I have to disagree with you first
of all Russian government is very
specific that's the Russian state you
made reference to multiple contracts I
only have read about one with this fella
Deripaska mm-hmm
which I was not a winner of at the time
but I still don't think it proves
Russian collusion so no again Roger I
want to I want every precise language if
we want to look at precise language you
did tweet on October 31st that Paul
Manafort has no Russian ties that's
different than saying he will have that
again having a ten million dollar
contract is a tie is it not I would
concede that and and look like he who is
without sin cast the first stone
well but that aside when I made that
retweet when you made that tweet on
October 31st was it a lie or did you not
know clearly I didn't know about the
Deripaska story because if I had I would
not have said that at the same time I
still think his relationship with
Deripaska does not constitute
collusion during the 20 2016 campaign
when the contract ended in 2009 okay we
are now starting to starting to hear
from from some Democrats exclusively at
this point that they believe ultimately
some of the individuals associated with
what they believe is collusion or
coordination with Russia will end up in
jail or prison in the United States well
what's your reaction do you think
everybody's gonna get off scot-free here
I'm like you I would like to see the
investigation I'd like to see these
hearings go forward right but you know
so much more than some of the people
waiting for the investigations of
knowing what you know what's your sense
well that's an assumption on your part
I don't know general Flint I've never
met him I've never had any
communications with him I know him from
watching him on television and I and I
cannot tell you
what he may or may not have done and
whether any of it rises to the level of
collusion he doesn't join the campaign
until the fall I have no contact with
him and I don't know I've read Carter
pages book he denies everything I don't
know the gentleman never met him had no
dealings with him best I can tell he
appended himself to a hundred member
issue Advisory Committee as some kind of
a Russian expert I'm not certain who
else you're talking about
I don't have a crystal ball but I do
know as far as I am concerned there is
no collusion or coordination of any kind
with any representative of the Russian
state all right let's pick it up there
we've been speaking with Roger stone he
is the author of the new book the making
of the President 2016 how Donald Trump
orchestrated a revolution he's not
kidding that he talks about a lot of
these issues in the book I've been
reviewing it before our interview for
the last week or so let's pause there
and pick up the conversation with him
tomorrow we're continuing our
conversation with Roger stone he's a
political consultant the New York Times
bestselling author and author of the new
book the making of the president 2016
how Donald Trump orchestrated a
revolution we wrapped up part one of the
interview with some more general
thoughts about what's going on in in the
current investigation let's see if we
can sort out what's true and what isn't
about your involvement in associations
have you ever met ambassador Sergei kiss
lyac I have not you've never met him and
never met him didn't know his name until
I read it in connection with senator
sessions meeting of course senator
sessions is a member of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee and because
he met with the Ambassador you can put a
negative spin on that but we don't know
what the cut with the content or subject
of the meetings is no and Jeff sessions
at first didn't even remember that the
meetings had taken place so I think that
Jeff sessions may not be the best person
to go to to figure out what the content
of the meeting was with regard to the
what's known colloquially as the steel
dossier
or the the Trump Russia blackmail
dossier call it what you will
were you on the Miss Universe trip to
Moscow in October of 2013 is that a trip
you were on I was not you were not and I
was with regard to that that trip or any
others can you definitively say that
Donald Trump has not ever consorted with
prostitutes with which is one of those
claims made in the dossier
yeah the dossier is you I think you know
kicked around for quite some time maybe
not shopped during the Republican
primaries it got shopped during the
general election most responsible media
organizations wouldn't touch it it's
rife with misspellings among other
things and some correct assertions as
well well the point I guess I would make
is that at the time of the trip I recall
Keith Schiller who was the head of the
security detail for now president Trump
telling me that his contact the person
assigned to be the contact with the
Trump traveling party on behalf of the
the pageant who presumably was actually
an agent for the government said that he
planned to send girls to mr. Trump's
room and was told under no circumstances
to do so and that Keith who's a very
smart guy posted guards at both the
front and rear entrances of the hotel as
well as the door to mr. Trump's room
also knowing him for forty years knowing
of of his germophobia mm-hmm knowing
about his penchant for privacy and I
just find it almost impossible to
believe I think that it is a whole cloth
the idea that Senator McCain would send
this to the FBI I think that should be
examined because I'd like to know what
he knew about the origins of this
document well because John McCain didn't
create the document so wouldn't the
obvious thing to do would would be to
send it to someone who can maybe try to
verify what the claims are and who the
sources I mean you're not suggesting
unless you're suggesting McCain created
the document
it seems that what he should have done
right send it to the though I'm
suggesting I'm suggesting as an
experienced individual of some judgment
he might have been able to look at it
and see that it is highly questionable
to say the least
too much has already been written about
something that I believe is entirely
fraudulent this did not happen it is so
out of the realm of the possibilities
for Donald Trump if you knew him that it
just has no credibility I also think
that we have traced mr. Steele to a
number of the neo-cons I believe that
that's where this was created the the
fellow who makes these assertions I
think is not credible well hold on a
second go Roger but that I think your
mudding the waters a little bit let's
disaggregate some of those claims it
seems as though steel was initially
hired to do opposition research on Trump
by other Republican candidates but mr.
Steele's credibility has not been called
into question by any serious individuals
no I don't I don't agree with that
continue but who that that we can go to
and say they have the knowledge that we
would we would believe people in the
political community who are operatives
like myself are familiar with mr. Steele
and his work he was also involved
peripherally in the case of the
poisoning by presumably the Russians of
a gentleman in London he pops up again
in the in the the Billy Bush tape matter
so I'm not sure that he is the best
source but my understanding was that his
source was a on-the-ground Russian who
made these claims okay
let's finalize the this this topic and
then we'll move on to some other things
so you said a lot of things about how
the the prostitution story is not
coherent with your 40-year knowledge of
Trump but are you saying definitively
that to your knowledge Donald Trump has
never consorted with a prostitute not to
my knowledge you know absolutely not
okay you've talked about your
willingness to testify on the
issue but you want to do it openly
rather than behind closed doors
simultaneously you've declined to say
who your mutual friend with Julian
Assange is if asked about that mutual
friend during the open testimony that
you want will you reveal who that
individual is well I think you call it a
source I mean I reported this on my
syndicated radio show I reported it on
my show on him force I reported it in my
weekly column no I'm not going to give
away a source who turns out to be right
this person is a reporter for a
reputable news organization in the
United States and what they told me was
exceedingly limited that there would be
a data dump on Hillary Clinton in
October it would be devastating and then
it would include everything which I took
to mean would include some emails or
some documents that had allegedly been
you know erased or deleted at the State
Department
now WikiLeaks essentially on July 31st
in a tweet says really pretty much the
same thing a tweet I was unaware of at
the time so my source is correct I don't
intend to give them up because I don't
want to cost them their job I'm not
going to expose our reporter in that way
but the information they gave me does
not fit the narrative that I knew in
advance and coordinated the scope or
thrust or content of the WikiLeaks
disclosures I also don't buy the idea
that WikiLeaks is a Russian asset it
doesn't matter how many times the
intelligence services want to say this
doesn't make it true even FBI director
Comey said when asked in the house
intelligence committees that their
assessment is that that Assange had or
the Russians had used some kind of
cutout that's right it some kind of
middle person yeah assessment to me is
usually a code for four we don't know
but we're guessing you have talked about
the poisoning that you believe you
suffered in
January and I want to talk a little bit
about that the the symptoms I've read
you had were fever rash and hair loss
and and you've attributed it to a
poisoning of some kind
well vomiting vomiting diarrhea night
sweats delirium yeah this was not a day
at the beach I don't recommend it for
for weight loss my doctor is convinced
that I was poisoned with some exogenous
substance which may have been
radioactive I have another blood test
this Friday I was very sick can I can I
prove who might have done this or their
motive no okay but let's pick it up on
it so number one is have you or would
you be willing to release something from
your doctor saying that their belief is
that the most likely explanation was
that you were poisoned for what purpose
I'm not an elected official or a public
official I have written my experience
people can make their own judgments okay
I don't I I don't want to dwell on this
I understand that others do because
because if so if indeed someone tried to
poison you that's a very interesting
story I mean who do you have any sense
of how you might have contracted the
poison before we leave this it could
have been consumed ingested in food or
drink it could have been surface
absorbed that has evidently been done as
you probably also know I was involved in
a hit-and-run accident this very same
day or the day after the House committee
expressed an interest in my testimony
where we were broadsided the the car
that hit us you couldn't detect who was
driving it because the windshield was so
deeply tinted and they took off now I
find that very suspicious the car was
riding in was was very badly damaged and
perhaps totaled the airbags went off but
whoever hit us didn't sustain enough
damage to their car that it didn't run
like ours
threw it in reverse and took off so
that's twice the the the sickness around
Christmas when I believe I was poisoned
happens immediately after Senator McCain
calls for my testimony the accident if
you want to call it that the hit-and-run
yes was filed with the police with the
Sheriff's Office happens the day after
congressman Schiff and others expressed
an interest in my testimony but Rodgers
and I asked the Hat I asked this in a
completely honest and open way if indeed
the goal of either or both of these
incidents was to prevent your testimony
from coming out don't you think that
it's almost sort of like too obvious to
do it when the idea of you testifying is
suggested why it's not like you were
going to testify the next day why not
wait a little bit it seems incredibly
haphazard well if you are trying to make
the case implausibly and incredibly
crazy as this is that the the Russians
wanted to take out stone to silence him
no I'm not making that implication I'm
just genuinely curious why why it would
happen it in that way in a way to me to
draw me to it has a certain logic to it
but then you know I don't know who I
don't know if there is a perp and I
don't know what the perps thinking is if
one exists yeah again I don't want to
distract from the fundamental question
of whether we can prove that there were
substantial and meaningful contacts
between anyone of in a position of
authority or influence in the Trump
campaign and the Russians I still don't
think that is the case no I know you
don't think that I know you don't think
that the last thing I want to touch on
and I know you've got just a couple of
minutes left
in retrospect you were one of the
individuals propping up the birther
theories of Barack Obama not being born
in the United States certainly you
encouraged Donald Trump that this is
something he should be public about and
look into number one thing yes your
parents was slighted that's a slight
overstatement I was never an advocate
for this point of view but I learned
about his interest in it and he asked me
what I thought and I said you know
follow your conscience if everything
you've read convinces you that there is
something there that's the thing about
Donald Trump no one puts words in his
mouth or ideas in his head he does not
work like a conventional politician I've
written talking points for you know
several presidential candidates yeah
several presidents Trump just doesn't
operate that way what's your current
belief about the birthplace of the
former president uh uh you know I don't
know I have looked online at the
document that he produced I have also
read a number of appearing ly
dispassionate you know internet experts
who questioned whether it's real I have
no idea whether it's real but he's no
longer president I'm not sure why this
is significant if you look at my tweets
feel-good things that I have written it
stone zone.com or you don't call I've
never written on this I've never tweeted
on it but yeah that's fine but you're
not you're saying you don't know that
the president was born in the United
States what would what would convince
you that President Obama was born in the
United States I'm not sure that I can
ever know for sure by the way I'm not
saying that he wasn't I'm all I'm saying
is I'm not sure but so you're saying you
can't even imagine hypothetical evidence
if it existed that would convince you
that bombings were in the u.s. I think
it is odd that all of his personal
records are sealed I think it is odd
that it took this long to produce the
birth certificate when he could have
made fools of his critics much earlier
instead this has festered I think it is
true that Donald Trump in a certain
sense was able to bring it from the
fringe into a more mainstream discussion
yeah but right now if you're telling me
that if you're telling me that there's
not even hypothetical evidence that
would convince you that the former
president was born in the u.s. you're
not really dealing in the world the
facts you've just decided you'll never
be convinced that that doesn't seem like
a very objective position if you're
saying I couldn't even imagine evidence
that would convince me of it and they
don't think no obvious
if somebody wants to if someone wants to
present me with the actual document that
we've seen copies of and it were and it
was certified to be real of course I
would accept it huh but no that's not
going that's not going to happen so I
only know what I have read about this
and I think it's curious and a number of
turns in the road the president says he
was born here it's irrelevant as far as
I'm concerned his presidency is over it
is indeed a fascinating guy yeah far
more important to me would be the
question of whether people in his
administration illegally unmasked the
names of certain US citizens who are
active in the Trump camp yeah and how
high you know this particular move went
well hopefully we will get answers to a
lot of the questions you and I have
raised during both parts of this
interview the book is the making of the
President 2016 how Donald Trump
orchestrated a revolution we've been
speaking with the book's author Roger
stone thanks for talking to us I know
you've been busy these past few weeks
many thanks for having me I enjoyed it
thank you